- One time when I was a kid,
I found a dead baby bird
on the sidewalk and I buried
it and then my dog dug it up
and then ate it and then puked it back up,
so I'm not really worried about this.
("Gentleman's Club")
- I grew up with a lot of Filipino folk
and they always told me about balut.
- I've heard about balut before
and I've always wanted to
try, I heard it's delicious.
- Yeah, I regret this.
- I'm excited.
- Let's do this, there's dark magic
and we're about to eat it.
- What I was taught, you're
supposed to crack the top
and then that forms like a little bowl
and then you're supposed
to sip the soup out of it
and then you just peel
this stuff and eat it.
(laughing)
- I'm so scared.
- Oh, boy! Oh, that's
a baby bird in there!
- Can I take it like a shot?
- Yeah.
- All right. Cheers!
- Cheers!
(imitating bird sounds)
- Oh, that's actually pretty good.
- Oh, it tastes just like broth.
- Delicious.
- Hmm, not as bad as
I thought it would be.
(screechy voice)
- Oh, my god!
- Oh, it's looking up at you,
yeah, that's pretty crazy.
- Are there bones in this?
(laughing)
- Eat that please.
- I notice the bone, you're lying.
(drowned out by food in mouth)
- I just squish and sprains, I think.
- I never thought I would say these words,
the fetus tastes good.
- The fetus does taste good.
- If this was common, it
would not freak me out.
This is just my first time.
I was a little bit
anxious for my first time,
but I don't think this is that bad.
- If I ate this even one more time,
I'm sure I'd be totally fine with it.
- Is that your hair or bird hair?
- That's my hair.
(laughing)
- I did it, I defeated you.
No, high five myself,
you didn't eat anything.
- I have a lot of respect for
the people who enjoy this.
This is-- you're hardcore
if you can eat this.
- I don't even like hard-boiled eggs,
I don't know why I'm here.
("Gentleman's Club")